este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a que
vi una plataforma para practicar inglés
de forma individual con tutores nativos
especializados muy pero que muy
interesante
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no es ningún secreto que últimamente la
república popular china no es
precisamente el país más popular del
mundo cosas como el coronavirus el
asalto a hong kong las constantes
amenazas contra taiwán o los problemas
con los préstamos a países pobres han
colocado a china directamente en la
lista de los países más antipáticos y
eso eso no es todo para colmo ahora una
nueva política está contribuyendo gota a
gota a machacar su popularidad en el
exterior me estoy refiriendo a la nueva
diplomacia establecida por xi jinping
un tipo de diplomacia mucho más dura y
beligerante que se conoce como la
diplomacia de un nuevo guerrero que
muchos analistas identifican básicamente
como una estrategia de chantaje y
coacción o una estrategia que la verdad
pues con datos en la mano no parece que
esté siendo particularmente efectiva no
al menos de cara a la popularidad del
país en el resto del mundo
fijaos un momento en este gráfico en
apenas 5 años entre la primavera del
2015 y el verano del 2020 la opinión de
china se ha desplomado en muchas de las
principales economías del mundo de ser
un país de moda a ser visto con muchos
recelos algo que en cierto modo tiene
que ver con la propia forma con la que
china se está relacionando con el resto
del mundo
queridos amigos amigas en este vídeo
vamos a conocer de cerca la llamada
diplomacia del lobo guerrero vamos a
echar un vistazo a la nueva forma con la
que china ha decidido castigar a
cualquier adversario que se cruce en su
camino pero antes antes os quiero hablar
de kemble una plataforma para practicar
y mejorar tu inglés que es súper
interesante con ella vamos a poder
terminar de una vez y para siempre con
la pesadilla más habitual en el mundo
hispano el dominio del inglés desde tu
casa y con sólo un ordenador podrás
conectarte con uno de los miles de
tutores nativos que hay en cambridge
estoy seguro de que encontrarás un tutor
a medida para ti en función de tus
necesidades que quieres mejorar tu
inglés aplicado a los negocios pues
tendrás tutores expertos en este campo
que lo necesitas para viajar pues
encontrarás tutores nativos que te
ayudarán con ello necesita es el inglés
para lo que lo necesites con complete
tendrás a tu disposición toda una
plataforma de clases individuales que se
adapta a tus necesidades y todo
cómodamente desde el lugar que tú
quieras y eso eso no es todo ahora para
ayudarte a conseguir tus objetivos que
emily te regala un cupón con un 50% de
descuento en todos los planes anuales
así es podrás aprender inglés todo el
año y seis meses te saldrán
completamente gratis e importante todos
los correos podréis probar el servicio
durante 10 minutos de forma
completamente gratuita sin compromisos
esto sí que es empezar con buen pie el
2022 no os parece introducirse el código
visual político 2022 en cambio a la hora
de seleccionar un plan y conseguirás
este descuento único no pierdas el
tiempo y empieza a aprender inglés desde
ya con tu propio tutor nativo
individualizado y dicho esto continuemos
[Música]
si no saca los dientes
querida comunidad de visor político la
china moderna da a la china de las
palabras mesuradas y las acciones
tranquilas parece haber desaparecido por
completo esa china tranquila que tanto
deseaba den xiaoping ha dejado de
existir si siempre ha terminado con ella
ahora es el tiempo de los lobos
guerreros
[Música]
la diplomacia del lobo guerrero no ha
supuesto un mero cambio de política
exterior sino todo un cambio de concepto
y de visión sobre el papel de china en
el mundo y sobre como pekín quiera hacer
valer su cada vez mayor peso económico y
militar es algo así como ya estamos aquí
y vamos a tomarnos en serio nuestro
papel
tan simple ya la vez tan complejo pero
ahora bien en qué consiste exactamente
este tipo de diplomacia cómo se lleva a
cabo qué cambios ha conllevado bien uno
de los cambios más importantes ha sido
el enfoque militar para ser un lobo
guerrero hay que ser capaz de infundir
miedo y eso es exactamente lo que ha
hecho china con las mejoras de sus
capacidades militares y con su creciente
nivel de beligerancia en la región os
hablamos de todo ello en un vídeo que os
dejo aquí abajo en la descripción sin
embargo el terreno militar no es el
único que ha experimentado cambios en el
nuevo estilo de diplomacia china va
mucho más allá del poder militar
la diplomacia del lobo guerrero es una
visión integral y la primera línea de
batalla se sitúa precisamente en el
personal diplomático buena parte del
personal de las embajadas y consulados
chinos ahora tiene la misión concreta de
alimentar la desinformación fabricar
fake news o buscar y apoyar a
periodistas y comunicadores afines la
línea roja se ha desplazado ya no se
trata de hilar fino sino de ejercer un
claro activismo cueste lo que cueste
digamos que la diplomacia china ha
descubierto las redes sociales
el ejército de fans falsos refuerza
mensajes de china en twitter claro que
esto ocurre en las redes sociales y
también fuera de ellas pero por supuesto
es sólo la punta del iceberg un
instrumento más en una estrategia que
tienen los castigos políticos y
económicos su elemento clave si se lo
habéis escuchado bien si bien quien ha
decidido que china tiene que castigar a
sus adversarios atentos porque con lo
que os vamos a contar a continuación
vais a poder comprender una parte
importante de la actualidad
[Música]
sacar los pies del tiesto con pekín y en
el precio
[Música]
el castigo político y económico por
encima del control territorial si tanto
rusia como eeuu francia o el reino
unido- llevan décadas preocupados por el
control territorial y la influencia
militar china está focalizando todos sus
esfuerzos en utilizar sus dos grandes
ventajas competitivas su posición como
la fábrica del mundo y su inmensa
población queridos amigos para conocer
cómo se las gasta el gigante asiático
tan solo tenemos que echar un vistazo a
los casos de corea del sur australia y
lituania tres países muy diferentes y
muy distantes entre sí que sin embargo
tienen algo en común han vivido en sus
carnes lo que supone enfadar a xi
jinping
en 2017 el gobierno de corea del sur
decidió autorizar la instalación del
sistema antimisiles estadounidense
en su territorio algo lo que china se
opuso frontalmente desde un primer
momento según pekín los potentes radares
estadounidenses podrían ser utilizados
para seguir los movimientos militares de
china en su propio país pese a ello en
aquel momento en corea del sur la
tensión estaba por las nubes por las
constantes pruebas con misiles
intercontinentales que estaba llevando
corea del norte así que a pesar de la
férrea posición china se terminó dando
el ok al despliegue del th ave
el resultado el gobierno chino promovió
una campaña salvaje de boicot económico
contra las empresas surcoreanas
el primer efecto fue la paralización del
turismo chino que se desplomó más de un
50 por ciento y le costó a las empresas
surcoreanas pérdidas multimillonarias
luego llegó el boicot directo a empresas
como ocurrió con el grupo lotes el grupo
empresarial surcoreano que era dueño del
campo de golf donde se instaló
precisamente el tat pues bien este grupo
tenía un importante negocio de
hipermercados en china bajo la marca
lotes mart a los que de repente la gente
dejó de ir digamos que el gobierno chino
se encargó de que estuviera mal visto
comprar en sus tiendas por supuesto
cualquier licencia para abrir nuevos
establecimientos quedó también congelada
la empresa tuvo que terminar anunciado
su salida completa de china de la misma
forma a millones de chinos dejaron de
comprar de la noche a la mañana de
inclusión daiki a móviles y
electrodomésticos de samsung y un largo
etcétera etcétera de productos de marcas
surcoreanas todo esto hasta que en 2019
dos años después del inicio de las
acciones chinas the king decidió que ya
había sido suficiente y dio asunto por
zanjado sin embargo otros países no han
tenido tanta suerte echemos un vistazo
por ejemplo al caso de australia
y es que veréis a pesar de su estrecha
alianza con los eeuu australia es un
importantísimo socio comercial de china
que provee al gigante asiático de todo
el carbón y hierro y gas que su
industria necesita y también de una
enorme variedad de productos
agroalimentarios de hecho entre los años
2009 y 2019 las exportaciones de
australia china se triplicaron hasta
superar ojo la barrera de los 110 mil
millones de dólares
todo saltó por los aires en 2020 cuando
el gobierno de australia pidió una
investigación internacional
independiente sobre los orígenes de la
pandemia del sars coronavirus 2 se fue
un auténtico punto de inflexión apenas
una semana después de la petición
australiana el embajador chino en
canberra amenazó con un boicot económico
algo que por supuesto no tardaron en
poner en marcha por ejemplo redujeron
progresivamente las importaciones de
carbón australiano hasta llevarlas a
cero e introdujeron un montón de
aranceles a muchas de las importaciones
que china compraba en este país
[Música]
a la carne el vino el cobre la madera el
castigo fue considerable
pero sabéis que el tiro a los chinos le
salió por la culata canberra no solo no
cedió sino que cambió por completo su
política exterior o suena de algo august
la nueva alianza entre australia eeuu y
el reino unido seguro que sí hemos
hablado de ella recientemente aquí en
visual político pues bien ese acuerdo
tuvo mucho que ver con la historia que
se estamos contando ya sabéis qué
casualidades las justas el equilibrio de
décadas de australia entre eeuu y china
ha terminado han elegido washington
boston obtendrá el primero de sus
submarinos nucleares cinco años antes de
lo previsto mientras eeuu acelera el
proyecto de 90.000 millones de dólares
frente a las crecientes tensiones con
china por cierto que la estrategia del
logo guerrero en el caso de corea del
sur pues tampoco valió para mucho estar
continuó desplegado a pesar del boicot y
es que si algo parece claro es que eso
de convertirse en el abusón de la clase
pues no le está sirviendo para nada
china de hecho el país de sir in pink
atraviesa su peor momento diplomático
desde que comenzó el nuevo siglo pero
aún no hemos terminado el último ejemplo
de estas campañas de acoso y castigo lo
encontramos ni más ni menos que en un
país de la unión europea en lituania
[Música]
preocupado por la creciente intromisión
política de china y tu área decidió
retirarse del grupo 17 1 una iniciativa
de pekín que buscaba aglutinar todos los
países del centro y este de europa algo
que en pekín no hizo ninguna gracia pero
con todo la gota que desbordó el vaso
fue la autorización que me newsday a
taiwán para que este gobierno abriera
una oficina de representación en la
capital lituana y que para colmo lo
hiciera con su propio nombre es decir
oficina de representación de taiwán en
lugar de oficina de representación de
taipei que es la fórmula más habitual a
partir de ese momento comenzó el castigo
el gobierno chino eliminó a lituania
como opción de origen en el despacho de
aduanas lo que implica que las empresas
de esta pequeña república báltica no
puedan exportar sus productos
directamente al gigante asiático
[Música]
y eso no es todo el gobierno chino
también está presionando a compañías
europeas que fabrican en la propia china
para que dejen de utilizar componentes
del país báltico este ha sido por
ejemplo el caso del fabricante alemán de
componentes de automoción continental
las exportaciones lituanas prácticamente
desaparecieron del mercado chino en
medio de la disputa de taiwán los datos
aduaneros chinos muestran en diciembre
una caída del 91 4% en las exportaciones
del estado báltico claro que tal y como
hemos visto en los casos anteriores el
castigo pues tampoco parece haber
servido de mucho
[Música]
y todavía de momento ha continuado
estrechando lazos con taiwán y ahora la
unión europea se plantea tomar
represalias la unión europea diseña
nuevas medidas contra la coacción
económica la comisión europea ya no
quiere soportar un chantaje económico
como el ejercido por china francia busca
una acción rápida contra china para
rescatar a lituania la guerra comercial
esto es algo de lo que hemos hablado
largo y tendido en las claves de la
semana el boletín que recibís todos los
que nos apoyáis en patrón
en fin de momento parece que la
diplomacia del lobo guerrero no está
cosechando precisamente muchos éxitos no
funciona en korea no funciona en
australia y no está funcionando en
lituania tampoco lo hizo en taiwán
cuando en 2016 china comenzó un boicot
contra el turismo y los intercambios de
estudiantes tras la primera victoria de
site web y no se puede decir que
funcionara en canadá con el caso menguar
su
[Música]
lejos de ello la posición diplomática de
china parece mucho más endeble y
expuesta de lo que lo era hace unos
pocos años en pekín parecen no saberlo
pero en ocasiones el diálogo la
negociación tranquila y los gestos de
buena voluntad consiguen mejores
resultados que la fuerza el chantaje y
la corrupción pero amigos llegado hasta
aquí turno para ti qué te parece la
diplomacia del nuevo guerrero empleada
por china cómo deben los países
afectados a enfrentarse a ella que
tienen que hacer las grandes potencias
internacionales déjanos tu opinión por
aquí abajo en los comentarios y como
siempre si te ha gustado este vídeo no
olvides darle a like y suscribirte a
nuestro canal para estar al tanto de
todas las novedades que están por venir
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]